hi everyone today we're gonna talk about
tools but first let me tell you about my
dad my dad was a tool maker and what
that meant in his context was he worked
in a machine shop and he went to school
for an extra year to learn some advanced
techniques so that he could make tools
the tools he made were used to make
parts or make it easier to make parts
that any other machinist could make and
there was two reasons why he was called
the tool maker as opposed to just a
machinist first was that he just went to
school for an extra year and learned
some things
the second was those tools well they
were very important to the manufacturing
process it was they're also very
important to saving time making some of
these parts so I won't think about that
a little bit today is there anything
that we do as developers that we could
save time that could be easier that we
could be more effective at and to do
that let's first discuss how linters
compilers and other cool things work I'm
will Klein I'm from Longmont Colorado
I work in Boulder as an engineer at
workday and today we're going to talk
about four things first what are our
problems what are the things that we
might be able to think about and improve
second I'm going to talk about compilers
because compilers are just really
awesome and typically you learn they
learn about that and hear science at a
university but I think there's some
really essential things that we can all
gather very quickly today and there's a
key piece of compilers that we're gonna
really dive into and make our best
friend and then we're going to look at
how that key piece can be applied to
those problems and hopefully come up
with some solutions so the first problem
that I run into a lot is with code
review and I don't have a problem code
of you I love code review I've worked in
a really lovely code review rich culture
for the past five years but but there's
some things I see in code review that
could be better
I love getting feedback
feedback I love asking questions and
learning about code just to the code
review but when something comes up that
is I'll say tribal knowledge I'll submit
my first PR to a project and they'll say
oh yeah that's great but when you work
in this part of the codebase there's
these other things you can use that you
didn't know about and here's where they
are so there's all these things that we
can only learn from code review or from
pairing with another developer that I
kind of wonder is there a better way
than waiting until we get to code review
to find out about those things and then
going back to the drawing board or re
rewriting our code and the second thing
that is actually really awesome are
changing language features we have since
es6 we have had so many iterations in
the language all these awesome new
features that have come about but I
wonder is there an easier way to apply
those to our existing code to bring
these new awesome things into our code
bases and take advantage of them without
having to change everything manually and
the last piece is very relate to that
API changes or even changing libraries
and frameworks we've seen plenty of
change and I've largely embraced it and
enjoyed it but when I need to switch
from one library to another and change
all the syntax it's all potentially
hundreds of changes in the code base and
it's just a lot of tedium and I wonder
can we also improve that cool so to do
that we're gonna take a step over to
compiler land and talk about compilers
really briefly so how do we turn this
into something that the machine can
understand how we turn a variable
declaration into ones and zeros that can
be put through the CPU and have awesome
things happen in our browsers there's a
little bit of magic but hopefully less
less of that after today Babel hell
gives us an awesome reference point
Babel is a type of compiler that takes
in source does some stuff with it and
then spits back out JavaScript source a
transpiler technically is what type of
compiler it is and it actually has
everything we need to to understand
and there's this really awesome
definition of a compiler that I'm going
to borrow Jamie builds on Twitter and
github writes this in the super-tiny
compiler most compilers break down into
three primary stages parsing
transformation and cogeneration okay
let's dive in each one parsing is taking
raw code turning it into a more abstract
representation of the code okay it's
taken that JavaScript code and turning
into something else that's more abstract
the second part is transformation that's
taking the abstract representation and
changing it to do whatever the compiler
wants it to do so in the case of babel
it wants to take potentially javascript
with es2016 2017-2018 features and so on
and do something with that trees so that
when it spits it back out it's going to
be in something like closer to es5 that
more browsers can support out of the box
and that's the code generation is
spitting that code back out and other
compilers might spit out something else
but babel just it's JavaScript back out
cool so we're going to focus on one
piece of this the abstract
representation because this is where all
the magic that we really care about
happens so going back to our code
example the first thing with parsing
that we mentioned is breaking this down
into tokens and there's just what are
those discrete pieces of code in this
line that stand on their own the atoms
in the molecule and this is just a array
of these tokens but from here we need to
figure out how to relate these tokens to
each other how does the VAR and the
answer bond to each other what is their
connection and the 6 and the x and the 7
what how are they related and how's that
tie back to the variable it's being
declared so to do that we need some type
of representation that representation is
called the ast and the ast does not
stand for whatever Marcy said it is
actually an abstract syntax tree and
that sounds very computer science II and
wordy but it's just a tree we don't talk
about trees a lot in web development but
we actually
work with them a ton the Dom is probably
the best example we have our HTML
document and that has a head and a body
the head has a title and meta tags and
the body has divs and those divs have
their own divs
so what a tree is essentially is just a
node at the top
it's weird trees are like upside down in
computer science world because it's the
node of the top there's a root and then
it can have any number of children and
then they can in turn have children and
they can also have properties on them
that describe them so we're gonna look
at this in a just another view in a
moment let me show you something called
ast Explorer so this is a really awesome
tool that's up at h to explore net check
it out we're gonna play with it today
and show you how it works it's a little
bit tricky to present with though
there's a lot of options and it doesn't
quite scale very well so I made a
special version a Cascadia J s edition
cool so right here we just have an empty
program file that's the same thing and
there's nothing here but already we have
a tree and right off we can see that it
has a program node this is the root node
in every program every file that's
that's parsed and it has three types of
properties that we're going to talk
about the first is its type and every
every node always has a type and this
will differ program at the top here and
the second type of property is where the
children live in this case there's a
body there's nothing there yet but there
will be and the third type is a
descriptive property describing that
node itself in this case it's describing
it as a source type of module all right
let's look at another example
let's look at those variables again so
now we can see that the program has two
children it has two elements here if we
expand that they are our two variable
declarations asu's are awesome and
Cascadia jess is love so the first
variable declaration there's a little
bit of a hint here say in the gray
saying hey as a type that has
declarations and as
find so the type we're familiar with the
declarations this is what the children
look like on a variable declaration
there could be more than once there's
just one here it also has a kind and the
kind is kind of cool because it's
describing whether it's a Const
or a let or just a bar that looks pretty
familiar let's dive deeper down the
rabbit hole for a moment looking at the
variable declared er this has two
properties besides the type it has an ID
and Internet doesn't have any
descriptive properties but it's got two
places where children live it's good it
has its identifier for a STS and then it
initializes that to this string little
for awesome so every node in the ast for
a JavaScript looks like this the node
type might be a little bit different
it's children might live in a different
place or it might not have children and
I might have different descriptive
properties but every node in JavaScript
and the ast can be related to this
example let's take it one step further
so I was talking about automating code
reviews before whoo you're seen code
like this who has seen code like this on
one line yeah that's a lot of hands yeah
so tools like e eslint are great for
this to look for patterns and language
and help us help us warn us when we're
doing things we probably shouldn't we're
gonna write an insolent role for this so
I'm gonna go over a transform on ASU
Explorer and pull up the latest version
of you slant and let me explain this for
a moment
so every is lint roll is essentially a
function this function returns an object
this object is where you can say hey
whenever there's a note of a given type
I care about that and whenever you find
it yes lint passed that into my function
here so this example is looking for
temple literals we don't have any what
do we care about here let me go back to
the Explorer if I click here cool so I
see conditional expression a bunch of
times pretty sure that's what turn areas
are called
that's the type so let's grab that and
let's yell if anyone uses a ternary cool
so over on this bottom right we see that
it's hade you have a ternary here you
have turnout here your three turn Aries
awesome cool
I don't need Turner's that much I think
they're great when they're appropriate
and they're just a single one so let's
narrow this down
and every year cilantro will do this
they'll say hey I care about this note
type but I'm gonna look for a pattern
and so what do we need to look for so we
talked about being nested and that's
where the the node is the node of the
same type is on the on the child and
there's three things on this node
there's the test this is the condition
it executes and if that conditions
truthy it returns the consequent if it's
false it returns the alternate these
consequence in these alternates these
are the children we care about and these
are the ones that have that nested type
so oh lord what happened to the bottom
there it is okay so let's grab that we
need to write a check just a little bit
logic here so we need to look at the
node and look at its consequent and
check its type and if it equals a
conditional expression or if I may copy
this that alternate is a conditional
expression
that's a little bit smaller Oh Lord
don't don't no no don't leave
live good it's fine I'll just give a
quick reload it is crashing hard cool we
make this bigger again cool so I just
have to fix a little bit of code here my
cursor is like not where I think it is
it's not prettier there it goes oh yeah
this is not because of ASC xplornet this
is cuz I hacked this like in the past
week instead of working on my
presentation at like the wrong hours of
the day cool so so now we're looking for
a conditional expression on either of
the children and now it's only warning
us about one thing and this is actually
in fact the insolent rule for nested
turn Aries let's look at one more
example let's look at transforms so
focus up here for a minute and we have
two objects they're essentially the same
when you have the key and the value is
the the same thing in this case X they
can be represented as X : X or in a
shorthand version that's just X super
convenient what I would like to do is
try to implement the Babel transform
that would make this first one with the
shorthand
output the same so we want to change
this part in the bottom right if we look
at a Babel transform the boilerplate is
a little bit different there's a
function that returns an object again
but that object has a name and a visitor
this visitor is actually the same as
that object in the eslint so we're going
to dive into that it cares about an
identifier right now in the boilerplate
it's reversing the the identifier making
them backwards that's funny so let's
change that to be what do we need to be
so if we look at X try this again
well we got this and never seen this
happen of course it's live so if I look
at this we've got an object expression
this is the object itself
it's got properties okay the properties
the object property has a short head
value this is the descriptive property
that we care about and it's false right
now so what do we need to do we first
need to care about object properties
prettier we first need to care about
object properties and then when we run
into them we need to do something with
that node so that node has the shorthand
value and we can just set it to be false
so is it was true before on the other
one and now we're changing it to false
now the output matches there's one more
thing we don't want to do this for my
lord we don't want to do this for for
every node so what we normally do is to
student if check and check the path no
touch for him if it's true thee only
then mutate the tree cool all right so
that is actually the all there is to the
object property or the object shorthand
property transform in Babel and this is
a plug-in in the insolent not the
estimate the Babel plug in the source
code stop here for a moment because this
concept of transforming the tree and
outputting something else also applies
to another tool called code mods with
code mods are is taking in some syntax
and changing it to some updated syntax
so we talked about new a new features in
JavaScript and we talked about API
changes and changing libraries and
frameworks we could do transforms like
this to take old syntax that we want to
update and automate the conversion
across our code base to the newer syntax
there's one more thing I'll point you to
this this website that just put up
yesterday called STS are awesome calm
and it has full background of everything
we've been talking about with links to
examples super
and compilers in there and some other
things so check it out after this for
more information cool
so I know we all heard neo say and the
matrix I know kung fu
but if Neil is a programmer and the
matrix is essentially made of code and
he's bending the matrix to as well what
I think he really meant to say is I know
some really sick ast transforms try it
pull up ast xplornet
and start typing code paste stuff from
from your project and see what it looks
like and the next time you're in code
review and you see something like oh I
need to tell you about this thing that
you couldn't otherwise know about think
about whether that was that can be
discerned filtered down into a pattern
that you can automate that you can write
in the iStent rule for here's actually
the first TS lint rule I wrote was for
this code we had this API request
function that would get data from the
server and it had a way of saying how
many records it wanted to retrieve you
know maybe like 50 or 100 something
reasonable but we had cases in our code
base that looked passed in the count of
infinity which would get all the records
and that sounds ok right
except users with lots of data you know
our big customers that love us so much
they would make this request on in the
browser and it would take forever and
after 30 seconds of a timeout and they
would just get a really bad screen that
didn't help them at all so we we need to
fix this but we had something like 60
plus developers in the front end code
across all the teams and this was like a
it's kept popping up here and there and
we could tell everyone but like how do
you just like tell everyone and then
tell the new person all that so we
automated this so we wrote an excellent
rule that looked for any invocations the
API dot request and looked at the
parameters passed in and then looked at
that that configuration object and
looked at the cow and made sure it was
something reasonable and if it was
something crazy like infinity we would
warn them nicely before code review
let's talk about API changes can we
automate those we had been using
glamorous in a project diamond now and
this is basically styled components CSS
and Jas actually is great great lately
and Kent C Dodds he we talked about him
yesterday he worked on this and he was
the first to say hey everyone
glamorous this glamorous is great but
motions even better we should just
deprecated and move to that so we have
lots of CSS lots of components we've got
to change everything in our code base
and it looks something like this this is
just glamorous takes in some some CSS
and and generates an element with that
style applied we need to change the
syntax from using glamorous to using
styled and instead of taking an object
in it needed to be passed a string
literal which is great because then you
just write real CSS and not like
JavaScript apply it turned out there is
a community effort to transform all the
instances of glamorous to emotion we
apply this in our code base and change
hundreds of lines in just a click of a
button and it was fantastic cool let me
tell you one more story I was at a Jess
coffe in Florida just conf us 2015 and
there was a young developer they got on
stage and he was telling his story and
we're something like this there was this
new thing called es6 there was a large
gap of my knowledge on parsers compilers
and generally the intricacies of
JavaScript so I decided to make an es6
transpiler to learn it called
six-to-five this was Sebastian Mackenzie
and 65 is now known as Babel now I am
NOT encouraging you all to go out and
write your own compiler we don't need to
but given Babel given eeeh Slynt given
some libraries for code mods and given
equivalents and typescript we don't have
to we can build plug-ins for these tools
we can write our own limiting plugins
that look like what I showed you we can
write transforms that can update our
code we can harness the ast and I
encourage everyone here this
is something for you to try I'm here to
answer questions on the internet or
after this I encourage you all to build
your own tools to help you and help
everyone else the Wrights JavaScript be
more effective JavaScript developers my
name is will Klein I'm on twitter at
wills lab thank you very much